vsauce kevin here a robot opened a door
why did tens of millions of people watch
this why is opening a door a big deal
well just five years ago there was a big
robotics competition and only one team
nailed the door opening challenge
getting robots to perform common human
tasks was the central feature of the
darpa robotics challenge a competition
sponsored by the us department of
defense that challenged robots to
perform in emergency and search and
rescue settings in 2013 a team from
florida institute for human and machine
cognition was the only one of 16
competitors to earn a perfect score on
the door opening task and many of the
two-legged humanoid bots fell on their
face
just five years later the four-legged
well-balanced austin dynamic spot mini
is capable of sneaking into your bedroom
as you sleep so for now four legs are
better than two for door opening robots
so why did this go viral it seems kind
of creepy to some people for robots to
bypass the human-made barriers of doors
and the reason that opening a door has
been difficult for robots to do is
because of the morvik paradox basically
that high level reasoning like computing
math equations doesn't require much
computational power but low level
reasoning like walking on a sandy beach
or opening doors requires a ton of
computational resources so things that
humans are able to do without thinking
biological skills that have been refined
over millions of years are really hard
to get robots to do and things we've
developed more recently like playing
chess are a lot easier so that's that
but that's not all because this is mind
blow
the dumbo octopus got its name because
its fins resemble the disney characters
big ears and for the first time we've
seen that baby dumbo octopuses are
actually born as tiny adults tim shank
of the woods hole oceanographic
institution in massachusetts used a
remote operated vehicle over a mile
below the ocean surface to collect
samples of what appeared to be egg cases
and then one hatched when the baby
octopod emerged it had all the
characteristics of an adult an mri
confirmed that from the outside features
to the central nervous system this rare
baby dumbo was fully formed and ready to
go he probably grew to be about 10
inches long and danced around like this
we know from mind blow 116 that rats are
heroes who can detect landmines and
diseases but they're also all around
nice folks researchers at the university
of saint andrews found that rats who
have had something nice done for them
return the favor rats trade food and
grooming services and it's shedding
light on our built-in instinctual
responses to kindness so next time
someone calls you a dirty rat say
thank you
i am kind
and i do need a bath
israeli remote knots have returned
safely from a four day mission on mars
d mars
just like high seas in hawaii the mars
simulation i visited for my planet
behind your eyes video the desert mars
analog ramone station in the negev
desert simulates the arid desolate
environment of the red planet inside the
makhtash ramon crater researchers can
undergo the daily routine of life on
mars and deal with its serious
limitations experiments from the first
mission included determining the optimal
materials for 3d printing on mars and a
psychological study of the correlation
between stress and language variability
in writing it turns out that research
subjects write less and use a smaller
vocabulary when they're under stress so
the first d mars simulation is helping
to show how our communication changes
when our environment changes the main
takeaway i had from the lavanauts i
interviewed in hawaii was that
developing technology to live on mars
will help us better understand and live
on earth which
seems good and now a word from 1981
there's nothing we want to watch on tv
tonight but we're still gonna watch
something great with our rca video disc
player and video discs just flip a
switch and on our tv we see airplane or
the pink panther the godfather of greece
muppets monsters mickey mash and a
hundred more starting as low as 15 and
the player cost less than 500. put it
this way we're watching a great movie
and you're watching us
[Music]
a new inkjet bio printing technique uses
common cells and molecules found in
biological tissue to create lifelike
tissue in the lab researchers at queen
mary university of london are using
droplet printing to assemble
bio-fabricated structures that can make
testing drugs or researching cancer
growth easier and the method utilizes
molecular self-assembly that builds
microscopic structures like lego
african modobili ants frequently raid
termite colonies and they never leave a
wounded friend behind research published
in the proceedings of the royal society
b shows that after intense termite
battles in which limbs are bitten off
and the ants are gravely wounded they
send pheromone signals as a cry for help
ants come to the rescue by picking up
their wounded carrying them home and
then engaging in intense licking
sessions that prevent infection until
the wound is healed the ants have a
two-step process that determines who can
be saved and who can't the mortally
wounded are passed over while the
lightly wounded are saved one model
calculates that reducing the mortality
rate in termite battles allows the ants
to have colonies up to 29 larger than if
they continually lost soldiers and they
demonstrate to us that even insects can
show compassion to come up with new
breakthroughs in science and technology
you can't just memorize formulas you
have to learn how to think through
complex problems brilliance interactive
problems are a great way for you to
really understand math and science they
have everything from 2d geometry to math
of poker or this one i really like on
physics of the everyday this crime
course allows you to use the physics of
a bike track to solve a murder
which way
did the killer go
so click the link at the top of this
video's description to get 20 off your
annual subscription your brain
will thank you
now i'm going to leave you with a video
telephone concept for shopping over long
distances
in 1961 and as always thanks for
watching
these are the shapes of the future
tools for communication now being forged
and tested against tomorrow's unfolding
needs
not yet
but sooner than you may realize
and some of what's on the drawing boards
may be a little out of this world
and now may we show you one of our
newest models designed by howard of hong
kong
notice the dramatically shaped bodice
and the gentle form of the neckline
this model comes in red
yellow
i don't know
do you have it in green
certainly here it is
yes fine that's it
i'll take it please send it out to me
here's my credit card oh and don't
forget the striped pillowcases no we
won't
we'll send them in the first delivery
thank you bye goodbye
there's an old saying
the more things change
the more they stay the same
[Music]
you